thank you for joining us America Jordan
is with us in San Antonio hey Jordan how
are you doing good Dave how are you
better than I deserve
how can I help well I'm in a predicament
that I'm sure about 95% of the men
listening would slap me for but my wife
has told me that she would like to give
me a not once in a lifetime but a few in
a lifetime chant of a hunting trip
and I'm all for it except it's very
expensive and it's kind of hard for me
to spend that type of money on a
three-day vacation for hunting you have
the money oh yeah we have the money
we're we're debt-free as of last month
and you know we'll have baby step three
done by the end of this month
but the hunting trip is almost six
thousand dollars and what is your ETA
what is your household income we make
just shy of one hundred and ten thousand
and um well if your emergency fund is in
place and you pay cash for it with your
income level I don't think that's
completely out of line it's uh I mean if
you called me up and said my wife and I
want to go on a cruise after 25 years of
marriage and we're going to spend $6,000
and we have our emergency fund in place
and we're debt-free and we make 110
we're going to pay cash for the cruise
I'd say yeah yeah and so this is this
kind of falls in that category I mean
except that you're kind of feeling
guilty you're going without her kind of
thing and all that and it's well it's
kind of like a daddy daycare
it's a family resort oh yeah they just
send out a way to go hunting for three
days yeah definitely I mean it's not I'm
very familiar with luxury deals like
that very very nice and my wife and
daughter will be with me oh they will
they're going with you okay but they
just won't be on the hunt itself okay
no okay um well I mean that's up to you
guys if that's how you want to do your
family vacation
yeah another option I guess is this
hunts like that have been around for
years it's not like they're going to
stop doing them this year if you wanted
to do something else and then do that
when you got to a different milestone in
your wealth building and you'd feel
better and you'd enjoy it more then
that's okay I don't think it's out of
line as long as the emergency fund is in
place you're debt-free you're making a
hundred and ten and you're paying cash
for the trip okay I guess I needed to
hear those words I take hard a lot of
things you say so your your opinion
means a lot to me yeah I appreciate that
but I mean you know you know the story
if you were in sitting there with $6,000
and credit card debt and we're choosing
between that and a hunting trip dude
you're paying off the credit card debt
we're being grown up you know but but
you've done the work you've gotten there
you guys are
obviously working together on some
things now I will tell you that Sharon
and I have done some outrageously
wonderful things over the years that
fall in the same kind of category that's
it this is called ultra-luxury stuff
okay that you're doing here and one of
the things we do is we match it against
our not dollar for dollar but when we
hit some milestones on our generosity
and we hit some milestones in our wealth
building then we'll do something like
that on a personal level and so it helps
us to kind of tickle Ong and know that
we're not becoming just consumers only
of things and that's kind of what's got
a little check in your spirit going here
I think you don't want to you just you
kind of feel like it's too much luxury
for where you are and it's close but
you're you know you're not you're
meeting the guidelines to go do
something like that if it means a lot to
you but if you would enjoy it more after
you had X number of dollars saved or X
number of other things done in addition
to being debt-free and having the
emergency fund in place you know you
wait a year and you hit some of those
milestones and then go and if you would
enjoy it more then then do it the way
you would enjoy it the most
we found that we enjoy luxury ultra
luxury things more when we correlate
them with mile
stones is what I'm saying the where
they're smaller and smaller and smaller
percentages of our life the money that
we spend on something like that we just
got back from it we did a trip between
Christmas and New Year's to Jamaica and
uh you know we did some great Dutton I
did some night dives with my son and you
know one of my daughters did a discovery
scuba the first time she's been down
she's only a family member not certified
we did several dives we did some
deep-sea fishing you know we did some
really nice stuff while we were there a
custom private everything you know that
kind of stuff and we dropped some coin
on that but it was a very small
percentage of our overall world and
therefore we don't sit and kind of wring
our hands and go ooh are we you know are
we going to hell because we spent money
on this is their child starving
somewhere in the world because we spent
money on this you know no we not at all
not based on our other generosity and
not based on our other investing and you
know we were not anywhere near
irresponsible and so it's easier to
enjoy it as all I'm saying and and so
you can decide whether that's this year
next year or the next year that this
fits in I can assure you that that hunt
is in your future it's just a matter of
which year it is and that you want to do
it and you'll enjoy it the most it's a
good discussion though Jordan thank you
for calling it see that that's a good
reminder for some of you because some of
you've gotten the idea somehow that
money is evil money is not evil the
bible does not say that the that money
is the root of all evil the bible says
the love of money is the root of all
evil and it's good to have a little bit
of a heart struggle like Jordan is
having or like I've had or some of you
have had a time or two we're going gosh
I feel like I'm doing something like a
little too nice for me that's a good
struggle because if you don't have that
you're just a hedonist I mean you're
just out searching for pleasure and
using up money to do it and then you'll
go deeply in debt go bankrupt and
everything else and you look like a fool
running around chasing stuff to make you
happy and because stuff won't make you
happy but that's not but the other part
of that the other side of that coin is
that enjoying the fruits of your labor
is
so biblical it's also biblical and so
for those of you that are people of
faith now you know your your your
spending on yourself as your wealth
increases should be an increasingly
smaller percentage of your world but
even then if you have a big world the
small percentage spent on you is more
than you ever dreamed you would do in
your life so I mean in other words
pretend that you do some of the stuff we
teach and you look up in a few years and
you've got five or ten million dollars
saved well that means that your
investments are creating a half a
million to a million dollars a year in
income if you spend a hundred thousand
of that on you that is completely ok and
that could be on quote luxury items
unquote that other people can't get
their head around and they the former
you couldn't get your head around I mean
the way I grew up I can't get my head
around some of the things I get to do
today and some of the ways some of the
things I do but I have 600 team members
here that I have to feed to and that's a
lot of payroll it's a lot of millions of
dollars a year tens of millions of
dollars a year and so I have to stop and
think about how we're doing things
around here all those kinds of things so
that you know this is the thing you do
is you keep your consumption at an
increasingly smaller percentage of your
income and your net worth because as
your income and net worth grows you
don't want us you don't want just go
bananas and all be about you it does not
bring you happiness it does not bring
you spiritual fulfillment but for those
of you who say that you should live in a
thousand square-foot house and drive a
one thousand dollar car when you have a
ten million dollar net worth because
somehow that's wholly
what you are biblically illiterate you
don't know anything about what you're
talking about
you've used your cultural toxic
upbringing to impose that value system
on other people so I want things I want
to teach you guys to do is not only
become wealthy and not only become
outrageously generous as you're on the
path to wealth and as you have wealth
but I want to teach you to enjoy it to
within ratios low ratios that allow you
to have fun with as part of the fruit of
your labor while you're being generous
while you're being a wise investor so
that's a really good call he made there
really good question that he's stirring
within his heart that puts this hour of
the Dave Ramsey show in the books hey
guys thanks for watching if you enjoyed
this video click the subscribe button to
get the latest content and check out
these other great clips from the show
[Music]
Oh